el jurado de este 74 festival de cannes
ya se encuentra deliberando en una villa
de la costa azul francesa como es
tradición allí tienen que elegir los
siete premios que se entregan hoy entre
ellos la palma de oro y para eso
realizan una primera votación por
mayoría absoluta una segunda por mayoría
absoluta y si no hay acuerdo una tercera
por mayoría relativa recordemos que es
un jurado excepcional que está formado
mayoritariamente por mujeres por primera
vez y por primera vez también presidido
por un artista negro como es el cineasta
estadounidense spike lee y desde hace
varios días que se escucha una favorita
la japonesa drive my car de yushu que
yamaguchi una película que cuenta la
historia de un director de teatro que
pierde a su mujer y viaja al sur de
japón allí conoce una chica que hace de
su chófer ambos tienen deudas con el
pasado y juntos intentarán superar
justamente esos dramas pero desde anoche
cuando se presentaron las dos últimas
películas en competencia también se
escucha como favorita me traen una
película australiana que está basada en
hechos reales en una matanza colectiva
que tuvo lugar en 1996 hoy en total
decíamos entrega en siete premios pero
anoche se entregó un premio para méxico
en la sección una cierta
mirad a la película de tatiana huezo
directora salvadoreña mexicana se llevó
una mención especial